My Roman Empire will always be
how my children react to the very real scenarios of parenting
that I was raised with
so I'm a cycle breaker parent
I am re parenting myself
I am doing the healing journey
I am parenting my children in a respectful and conscious way
very differently than how I was raised
very differently than how I think a lot of millennial parents were raised
so when my children
my older children were 9 and 7
find out some of the ways that I was parented
their mind is blown
cause we have lots of conversations about how we handle our big feelings
how we handle our emotions
and I was having one of these conversations recently with my daughter
and I said that I had to learn all of these skills as an adult
which is why I'm teaching them now as children
because it'll just be a lot easier
so my daughter is brilliant and she has tons of questions
she's like okay
well if you were not taught how to like
handle your emotions well
what happened to you when you had big emotions
and she's 9 she's heard a little bit about it
but I told her about having to stand in the corner
told her about time out
and I told her that I had soap or chili peppers part of my tongue
if I talked back or used a bad word
the jaw dropped and she goes
why would they do that
and I had to explain to her it was cause they wanted me to hurt
they wanted to cause me suffering as a punishment
and she made this face
and then said
I'm really glad you guys aren't doing that to us
the cycle is breaking